Christine was hoping to get compensation
for living life with a shortened arm she
believes it was caused when she was in
the womb by the drug primidos which her
mother was given by her GP to use as a
pregnancy test
but today's ruling against the claimants
is yet another setback for a campaign
that has been running for over 40 years
I don't mean to be too melodramatic but
it does feel like they're just waiting
for us all to die you know us babies are
dying younger than we seemingly should
our our mothers our parents are getting
older and
how much longer is this going to go on
Christine was among campaigners who
attended Court as the manufacturer and
Government tried to strike out their
claim based on the fact that they didn't
have enough evidence nor the funding to
go to trial Mrs Justice Yip agreed
saying the claimants have only limited
funding through the funds of the
association charitable fundraising and
crowdfunding there's no evidence that
they're likely to secure the funds
necessary to progress their claim she
said it hadn't been disproved that the
drug damaged babies in the womb but nor
could the claimants prove that it had
the alarm about the drug was first
raised by scientist Isabel gal in 1967
her research in nature magazine
suggested a higher number of babies with
spinal defects had been born to women
who'd used the pregnancy test drug but
the drug remained on the market for
years until further studies pointed to a
link with other abnormalities in the
fetus and a warning appeared on the
packet in 1975 saying primitus must not
be taken unless it's certain that the
patient is not pregnant a review team in
July 2020 led by baroness kumblage found
the drug had caused avoidable harm and
should have been removed from the market
years sooner the government apologized I
want to issue a full apology to the to
the those who've suffered and their
families but having apologized the
government's never properly explained
why it subsequently found itself on the
side of the manufacturers hiring lawyers
to ensure that this case never got to a
full hearing
the reputation of the manufacturer Bayer
has been upheld by this ruling but the
value of a government apology is much
diminished campaigners like Christine
say they will fight on Jason Farrell Sky
News